it is recording
brilliant it's recording
okay welcome hello everybody and welcome
to today's
webinar which is all about networking
strategies for your career advancement
my name is jackie lawrence i am one of
the career coaches at udacity
and i'm joined today by my colleague
mira who will be assisting me in the
chat room so she'll be there to pick up
any queries you may have
and also she will assist me at the end
of the session when we do our q a
webinar
um or our q a part so um mira thank you
so much for joining me today
and for your support so let's move on to
our next slide okay so
it's just going to be a little bit about
me so who am i like i said i
am jackie lawrence what do i do well i
am a career and business strategy coach
so from a career coaching perspective
i work with students i work with
individuals already established in a
career
transition to something else so if
you're wanting to shift
to a different career pathway whatever
field or category it may be
i support that i also work the people
who may be looking to climb up the
corporate ladder
or with individuals who may simply want
to explore what are their career
opportunities
in addition to that i do business
strategy coaching this is where i work
with
individuals who may be sole traders
business owners
entrepreneurs and i help them to build
successful businesses
by enabling them to create their
visionary roadmap and bring it through
to
reality by identifying opportunities for
growth and development
and then defining how are they going to
get to where they are now
to where they want to be so when i'm not
working what do i do well i enjoy
traveling
believe it or not even in this sort of
19 period that we're going through i did
manage to get away and travel
um but i'm i'm glad that uh that all
went well i'm back safely glad to say
that um it was a different travelling
experience
but um i'm still going to hold on to
that and i also do korean yoga
and i really enjoy participating in
charitable events
okay so let's move on to our next slide
and that is going to be telling you
about
what we are planning to cover today okay
so all it is
that's next is really our agenda for the
day
and we already jackie to interrupt is
everyone able to see the presentation
just type yes in the chat please
yeah yeah i'm seeing okay perfect
okay great okay sorry everybody okay
let's move
on to that's it slide three
so this is just the topics we will go
through today we're going to kick off
with
importance of networking for your career
development
so let's move on to our next slide so
i um would like to start this session
off really with a poll
and what i'd like to understand is where
are you in your career journey
so each of you here where are you are
you doing a career transition or going
through a
career transition or hoping to
transition to a different career
are you looking for a new role or are
you seeking internal promotion
so i'm about to launch the poll now
and hopefully you can all see that
okay so that poll is launched and i'm
gonna give you a minute now to let me
know
where are you in your career journey
okay
oh it's changing
quite a lot of you are transitioning
it's great
looking for a new role yeah
that's great
i'm going to give it a bit longer 78
of you have voted so we could we've got
room for more of you to continue
to put your votes in career transition
looking for a new role or seeking
internal promotion
okay okay we're at 83 percent gonna give
it a minute
see if we can get it up higher
fantastic okay
we're in our last 10 seconds
and then i will end the poll it's an
interesting
actually and i don't know whether it's
because of covet but the outcome seemed
interesting
okay looks like that's it oh one or two
more coming in
okay i'm going to end the poll
okay so in third place the majority of
you seem to be
career transitioning so that's 49 of you
looking for a new role 41 percent of you
and 10 of you are seeking internal
promotion and i don't know maybe some of
you your views and perspectives have
changed
as a result of covet maybe pre-covered
um more of you might have decided to
transition but i know and i can
appreciate that some of you
have may have decided to stay put in
your field and then are looking to
transition and the whole point
of doing this is that your approach to
networking
will differ according to whether you're
looking to transition into a new field
whether it's a new role or whether
you're seeking internal promotion
so as we go through this webinar just
bear that in mind okay
um you know some bits are going to be
more relevant for people looking for a
new role some bits are going to be more
relevant for people
doing an internal promotion and some are
going to be for transitioning
okay so let's end that poll
and we can now move on to our next slide
okay so moving on
so why don't we start by getting clear
on what do we mean by networking well
networking is about establishing and
nurturing long-term mutually beneficial
relationships
with people you meet another definite
definition i
came across which i think sums it up
pretty well is from the author
of never eat alone which is a networking
book in itself
and the author is keith ferrazzi and he
defines it as
today's most valuable currency is social
capital
defined as the information expertise
trust
and total value that exists in the
relationships you have
and social networks to which you belong
so given that networking is considered
such a valuable currency
what is it about networking that puts
people off
well some people say it's too time
consuming maybe you don't feel
comfortable
talking to people you don't know maybe
there's a fear of rejection
it could be that you don't want to tell
other people your business
you may be just a case of you lack the
understanding about how to network
effectively
or maybe you're an introvert and you
feel uncomfortable about putting
yourself
out there do any of these reasonings
sound familiar to you
well it is estimated that up to eighty
percent
of new job hires are in the hidden job
market
what do i mean by that well basically
eighty percent of new world are never
publicly advertised
instead they are either filled
internally or through networking
so whilst networking may not be at the
top of your agenda
if you want to get access to the hidden
job market particularly in this current
environment
where the number of roles advertised
have been reduced and there are hardly
any face-to-face meetings taking place
virtual networking is an area you need
to give some priority to
so let's look at the next slide and so
moving on there
when you've got so many things to juggle
so you've got your work your family
commitments keeping up with your nano
degree
you're probably thinking i don't have
time for networking or if i'm going to
be plowing a lot of effort into this
what will i get in return well here is a
couple of the benefits of effective
networking
what will you get in return well you can
get access to skills and resources
a network which includes people with a
range of skills and expertise
enables you to exchange your information
in return for their expertise
it can help you boost your career more
jobs like i said are filled through
networking than advertising
so networking provides referral
opportunities
it can help you to stay on top of the
latest trends in your industry
so i'm sure you've had occasion
particularly pre-covered where you might
have gone to face-to-face networking
talk to somebody in your industry or an
industry you want to move into and
they've mentioned
something totally new that you haven't
heard of before that's trending
right so these are some of the benefits
it can help you improve your performance
the more people you know in your
organization the more
people or experts you can call upon when
you need to get something done
or if something goes wrong it enables
you to meet prospective mentors
employers partners or clients for your
business
moving on to the next slide just two
more benefits to add
it can give you enhanced visibility so
it can be really easy to be overlooked
for promotions or new job opportunities
networking ensures that you stay visible
to people both inside your organization
and outside your organization it can
help you to gain access to resources
and companies that can help foster your
career development
so just moving on to the next slide
i'd like you to share your thoughts so
just share your thoughts on what do you
struggle with when it comes to
networking so what exactly is it that
you struggle with when it comes to
networking
can you just type your comments in the
chat below and
me and mira will take a look at them so
what is it that you struggle with can
you pinpoint it
yes have a look
yeah ignored
referrals yeah breaking the ice
definitely we're going to be covering
breaking the ice
where to go to network yeah
feeling like you don't have anything
interesting to say breaking the ice is
coming up a couple of times
not knowing what to talk about yeah and
i can totally understand so
many of these points we're actually
going to touch as we go through the
webinar
and so it's great that you're all
mentioning these because it means that
hopefully you should get a lot of
helpful points out of this
yeah i can see people are still
commenting that's absolutely great
thank you the right group of people
that's great not knowing how to proceed
how to reconnect with former colleagues
okay great these are all helpful
all right okay so let's move on
so that you can find out more about what
you can do and the steps that you can
take
so moving on to our next slide and
that's going to be all about
cultivating a mindset for networking so
whether you're looking to transition to
a different career or an internal
promotion or applying for a new job in
your current field of work
you really need to cultivate your
mindset for networking
as you start networking or for those of
you who've already started networking
and are looking to increase your network
keep these points in mind right it's
the quality of your network that matters
not the quantity
now some of you may have thousands of
people in your network
but do you really know who those people
are do they serve a purpose
can you help them you don't know unless
you go through
your network how many of those people
would you be comfortable contacting and
asking for a referral
or sharing your career thoughts with
also don't wait until you're about to
start applying for a job
or going for that internal promotion
before you start networking
when is the right time to start
networking now okay
you should always be networking as it
takes time to develop
relationships when you're initiating
relationship with people
do it with authenticity and generosity
so don't keep talking about your
personal agenda right
do some research before you connect with
someone
do you share any confidence and interest
with them that you can point to when you
reach out to them
do they have some amazing achievements
often when we acknowledge
others achievements they warm to us
quicker right you know how you feel when
someone's speaking to you and they
mention your background or
they mention you know that they see
you've achieved this award or what
you've accomplished
so our human nature gives us a desire to
be valued and appreciated
remember building up a good network
takes time it's not a sprint
you must be willing to invest time and
energy and that's right
time and energy into building up good
relationships
you will find that you get out of it
exactly what you put in
whether you're communicating via email
or phone
people can feel your energy i'm sure
you've all had instances where you've
either been speaking to someone on the
phone
or you've been at a face-to-face meeting
and they just don't seem engaged
you can tell and sense that they've been
distracted by something and it can be
quite frustrating
be strategic in who you network with
so think about who you really should be
connecting with
do you really need to be connecting so
let's say for example
you are for example a machine learning
engineer and you may be looking to
transition to product management so then
you need to think about do you really
need to be connecting with another 50
people with expertise in machine
learning
your efforts need to be directed in the
direction
you want your career to move remember
networking is a two-way process
be willing to pay it forward what does
that mean
so some of you may have heard about the
pay forward concept so do a good deed
for someone else
and then they will feel inspired to do a
good deed for another person
and so forth and so forth so sometimes
you may find yourself in the position
where you can provide some value to the
other person first
if you do don't hold back the value you
get back may not come directly from that
individual
but they may refer you to someone else
who opens the door for you
so moving on to our next slide we have
another poll
for you and this poll is
about where do you go to meet new
connections so
i'm interested to understand which
platform do you go
to meet your new or find new connections
um and this is really in the context of
of work
as opposed to all your career
development as opposed to personal so
i'm about to launch
this second poll
and this is poll number two
here it goes so do you go on linkedin
facebook slack other professional
networking groups or is it a case that
you haven't done any networking yet
because you're not sure where to go
how to go about it okay so where do you
go to find new connections
okay it's interesting
a bit of variety oh interesting okay
okay we're doing well we've got 75 of
the votes in brilliant
okay all right good
doing well on this one wow
okay i'm gonna give it about another 15
seconds we're at 82
so we're almost there and get it a bit
higher that'd be great
okay brilliant
okay that it we're at
jackie is this a multi-choice question
one of the students is asking
or have you kept it as a single choice
question i've kept it as a single choice
i know some of you
may have actually and i should have
clarified that some of you may have
actually used more than one
platform but what's your preferred
choice so what's your number one choice
that you tend to go to first
um when you're looking for connections
in order to
increase your your professional network
okay all right
uh jackie one of the students has asked
whether they can also see the results
i think uh usually it comes up for the
students and they are able to see the
results
but today when i'm not able to see the
results it's not visible so maybe some
tech issue
yeah it might be yeah sorry about that
normally you can see the results i'm not
sure why it's not showing today let's
see if it does show this time round okay
all right so three more seconds and i'm
going to end it because we're at 90
i think 86 all right let's end this poll
so you guys hopefully let me know if you
can see these results
okay i'm gonna share the results
can you guys see that so at number one
yes
brilliant okay so where do you find you
can number one
is linkedin right um
followed by i haven't done any network
so 20 21
if you haven't done any networking then
about eight percent of you
have um gone via professional networking
groups three percent slack
nobody has put facebook that it's very
interesting there are a lot of groups on
facebook
funny enough um and it's interesting uh
i'm gonna stop sharing the results
there is no wrong or right answer okay
this is all about um preference the
different platforms have a different
culture
um linkedin is often referred to known
as the professional flat
um platform facebook has a number of
interesting groups
and some people may find that actually
the personality of the individuals who
are in the groups on
facebook are very different from
linkedin so i know my experience in
terms of
joining groups on both platforms i have
found that people on facebook in
facebook groups
are much more helpful in terms of um
people will express their
vulnerabilities and say i need help in
this area or how do you do that and how
do you do this
and you will find that 20 or plus
comments or people come forward with
views
i just find on linkedin people are a bit
close more closed
in terms of sharing their views and
their opinions they're much more guarded
slack again has a has a different
culture so do try you know don't be
scared to try the different groups
to see which ones work best for you for
different things
great all right everyone thank you very
much for your participation
in that poll and now we can move on to
our next slide
and so i've got to talk to you now about
formulating your networking strategies
so before you start connecting with
people
think about what it is that you hope to
achieve from networking
is it information is it advice
are you looking for a referral or job
leads
what is it that you're planning to do
right is your aim and goal to transition
to a different career
are you looking to get a job at your
ideal company so you've got a target
company
whichever it is that you're planning to
do start
mapping out your network so this is
about going through
your current list of contacts on
linkedin on
facebook or professional networks in
your iphone or your
your whichever type of phone that you
have your samsung your galaxy whatever
um voluntary groups and categorize them
and literally i mean categorize them
in terms of what profession are people
in
um you know where do they work
how experienced are they you might try
and categorize them in different ways
i've got a particular template that i
like to do a framework and i'm going to
share that with you
on the next slide so that you can see
and get a better feel an example for
what i mean by
mapping out your network so here's an
example of a network mac pin table
and you can see i've got four columns at
the moment and in it the first one is
name of connection so what's the name of
your connection i've used joe blogs as
an example
what is their functional role so joe
blogs here is a senior data scientist at
xco
contact details so if you wanted to
contact joe blog
how are you going to contact him is it
on linkedin is it on slack
you might put a telephone number down
and then what is the purpose of
connecting with them
are you connecting with them to set up
an intimational interview
are you looking for a mentor what's your
purpose
and then you could also add a fifth
column
right and the fifth column you could
call outcomes or comments
so in this fifth column this is where
you set out any follow-up points so for
example if you had an informational
interview or a referral request
was what's the outcome of that
informational interview
do you need to follow up with joe blogs
in three weeks time
um is it a case of you asked for a
referral and the person said they can't
help you so maybe you're going to take
them off your
list so really think about um your
network and really you need to refresh
it from time to time right
uh it's not saying that you'll get rid
of people who you feel can't do anything
for you but really kind of think about
who's in your network why they're in
their network and not just what they can
do for you
but maybe how can you add value or how
can you help them
okay so moving on to the next slide
we are going to look at something that
came up earlier on when i asked people
what do they struggle with
breaking the ice so um a common fear
that people have
when it comes to networking is what do i
say
and so um it is you know kind of like
you know what am i going to say okay
yeah i want to go i'm interested you
know
where do i start and so one of the best
places to start is developing an
elevator pitch
okay and this really will help you break
the ice and for those of you
who may not be familiar with elevator
pitches it's basically a short summary
of you about yourself
which should communicate your skills and
attributes
in a competent way right so it's really
a short summary
why is it called an elevator pitch well
basically
you should be able to deliver it in
about 30 seconds to one minute which is
deemed to be the time it should take you
to get to the top of the building when
you're in an elevator so hence the name
elevator pitch what can you use this for
well you can use it for
internal so whether you're within your
organization as well
or external networking you can use it
for job searches
and you can use it for interview
and you know when you're using it for
interview the example is where you would
use it is if they ask you
tell me about yourself well really you
know your elevator pitch should deliver
that succinctly
right it's not about going through your
whole resume but succinctly
summing up in a short brief summary you
know
your background what you do and where
you're going
so let's have a look at a framework for
putting an elevator pitch together so
let's move on to the next slide
so before we do that apologies let's go
back a step i'm just going to tell you a
bit more about creating
your elevator pitch so when it comes to
actually creating it and you're thinking
about well what do i say
you know how should i structure it start
by thinking about the objectives of your
pitch so
are you in the process of a career
change again are you seeking a promotion
so you're going to want to introduce
yourself um summarize
what you do and your experience share
your strengths
and your unique selling points and when
you're doing
this when you're sharing your strengths
or your unique unique selling points
this is where you need to make your
connections so
this is where you want to connect what
you do
or what you want to do to what the
person you're speaking to does
so for example maybe you're
transitioning to digital marketing
and the person you're speaking to is a
manager as an advertising agency
so there you go you've now connected to
that person you you know that's the
person you're speaking to you're doing
digital marketing
you need to speak into their world
basically
okay then you're gonna want to going to
want to share what you would like to do
in the future and why
that's your your real connection
connecting that stronghold
and then try and keep this structure in
mind before an interview or a networking
event
and practice so your pitch is going to
be evolving it's not going to be static
as you go through experiences and as you
continue your studies
and your thoughts change about what you
want to do and what maybe what industry
you want to work in
you'll find that it evolves so you're
going to need to refine it
practice it and turn it into a
conversation let it flow
right it should flow okay
the other thing i would just say is
avoid including
things like hobbies interests cliche
words
keep it simple right don't start using
really technical jargon
um and also avoid anything too personal
speak naturally
slow it down use plain language and like
i say
not lots of czech jargon and express
confidence
right unless you're able to express
confidence when you're delivering your
pitch it loses its effectiveness which
is why
it's important to practice it yeah you
want to deliver it
confidently okay so let's move on to the
next slide and this is where i've got
the elevator pitch framework
so as you can see the first bit is about
who are you hi
my name is and yes you do need to say
who you are
um what's your background okay so i've
got it in two ways my name is so and so
i
am you then you would fill in the
position um or title
with x amount of years of experience in
whatever the industry is
or you might go for the second version
which is my background
is in x industry and my work focuses on
whatever your niche is
what you enjoy doing creating developing
building
and then you would move on to say i
continue to pursue something like a
personal growth and development
and i'm currently exploring
opportunities in x and then you didn't
just
insert your desired role or position so
that you can
how would you contribute okay so it's
who you who are you
what's your background make the
connection or present your unique
selling point
um the final thing you know and it all
depends on
how well you connect with the person but
the final thing you may want to do
if you're feeling confident enough and
you feel that the connection is there is
ask for what you want
okay so what do you mean by ask for what
you want isn't that too upfront some of
you might say
but this depends like i say in the
context of the person um
on the context of where you are and the
person who you're speaking to
but for example if you're looking for a
mentor and you would like to explore
that possibility
then simply ask them do you do mentoring
or you might say i'm looking for a data
analyst role
and wondered if you could tell me the
best way
and time to apply for an opportunity
with your company
you know the saying if you don't ask you
don't get right
and so i've just kind of put a brief
summary
or a brief example of how you might put
one together
so i'm just using this as an example but
i don't have a business analytics
background
um but i'm gonna use this anyway so i
say hi my name is jackie it's a pleasure
to meet you
i have a background in business
analytics with just over eight years of
experience creating data-driven
solutions
for various business problems in
fintechs i enjoy working with data
creating new concepts and i'm
continually looking to grow and develop
my skin
skill set i'm currently exploring
opportunities as a data analyst
as i have had great success in strategic
evaluation of data analysis with our
management team
so that's just kind of a brief example
of how you might put one together
in practice okay so let's move
on to our next slide which is
our third pole pole time and i'm
interested to know
if you have an elevator pitch how do you
feel about it so i don't know how many
of you have an elevator pitch
how do you feel about it do you think
it's brilliant do you have one but
hardly use it
do you have one but feel actually it
needs improving or is it okay that you
just don't have an elevator pitch
so i'm gonna launch this third pole
now okay let's find where's it gone
here goes okay are you ready just
launched it
so if you have an elevator pitch how do
you feel about it
it's brilliant i hardly i have one but
hardly use it or i have one but it needs
improving
or i don't have an elevator pitch and
that's absolutely fine if you don't
that's what you're
you're here for okay
ah okay
if you have an elephant pitch how do you
feel brilliant
i have one okay numbers are coming in
okay we're at 81 let's see if we can get
it a bit higher good
82 going up a bit more be great to get a
couple more votes in
yeah okay 82 can we get it a bit higher
a bit more bit more i'm gonna give it
11 more seconds we're coming down to
coming up to one minute
and
okay
let's end this poll okay
all right so the results are in and
interesting enough i shall share the
results with you guys
you will see 48 of you
have voted that you don't have an
elevator pitch absolutely fine so
you're here for to have a framework to
start working on one
34 actually have one which is great
but you acknowledge that it needs
improving um
you know and by all means you know you
can work on it of course you can also
book a session with a career coach to
work on yours um
16 of you you actually have one but
hardly use it
and two percent of you think it's
brilliant well that's great if you think
it's brilliant fantastic
but i can see that a lot of you don't
have one so that will
probably be something that you really
need to think about putting together and
those of you
who have one but need to improve it will
probably have to shed your time to work
on it
and also those of you who have one but
hardly use it think about now the
context in which you can start using it
okay
okay now i've closed that
okay so let's move on
to the next slide
okay so as we said
your professional network can help you
find jobs and unlock new opportunities
right so this is really going to be a
case of focusing
now on where you can network and i have
chosen at the moment just for this
purpose is
i know there are many networking
platforms but for the purpose of this
webinar i'm going to focus on linkedin
and i know a lot of you network
principally on linkedin
so when it comes to building up your
network on linkedin your professional
network as we said can help you find
jobs and unlock new opportunities
so if you're just starting to network on
linkedin start
by connecting with people you know so
friends
family colleagues then
reconnect with people you haven't spoken
to in a while
so when you're connecting and
reconnecting particularly with people
you haven't spoken to in a while
send a personalized message okay
personalize it like where'd you meet
them from where do you know them from
you know and you might want to say hey
i've just really you know i've just
started really networking
on linkedin i'm looking to reconnect
with people i've worked with in the past
or make that connection how do you know
them where do you know them from
okay and just reach out to people on a
personal basis
a lot of people just sent blank
connection requests
and you know that doesn't make you very
memorable so that's why you really want
to personalize it
be visible okay so as your confidence
creeps up on on linkedin and you get
your confidence up share insights
your experiences your ideas some of you
i know already write blogs and some of
you put them on medium
but think about sharing them on other
platforms where you engage with people
those of you who are going through a
career transition or a career change
connect with people who work in the
industry you want to transition to
so you will probably most likely have a
lot of people in your network already
who are in your current industry and
that's not going to help you make that
transition so now you need to start
reaching out to people
in the industry that you want to work in
and as i mentioned before you want to
send a personalized connect request
and also one of the things you can do if
you haven't already done so is join
linkedin groups that cover your field of
interest
so there are a number of of groups on
linkedin techfoscast and otherwise
some will focus principally on data
science some may focus on machine
learning front-end development
find a group for you and i'm going to
talk about and show you how to do that
search on linkedin
um in a slide coming up so let's just
move on to the next slide
and again we're still talking about
building up your network on linkedin
so if you um sorry let's just move on
to the next slide so i'm just making
sure
we are now on searching for groups to
join
okay so just talking about the group
thing
um you all know what you're doing what
you're studying and so in this example
you'll see a screenshot from linkedin so
this is my linkedin page
um and i've done a search for product
manager groups right
so product managers so i basically gone
into the search field on linkedin i've
typed in product manager
and what happens is you will get a drop
down so when you type in your area of
interest a list will drop down
with the options by which you can search
for a group
you click on groups so it will give you
people groups that will give you other
options you click on groups
and it then gives you a list of groups
you could potentially join
and you can see here it's got sort of pm
community
and the accidental product manager you
can also see the number of members in
each of these groups
and so take some time when you're
looking for groups to join particularly
if you're transitioning
because the value of being in these
groups means that
it's a good way for you to start growing
your network with
other people who are already working in
your industry either well established
at mid-level junior or also aspiring to
get into it
okay and you can also get lots of
learnings from these groups
some of these groups are very
fast-moving so some of you who may have
joined groups may find that actually
yeah there's a lot going on
in the group some of the groups may be a
bit stagnant so you might find nothing
happens for
like a week or two weeks or three weeks
and then suddenly there might be a burst
of activity
so um choose your groups wisely
and you won't know until you're in a
group and there's nothing that restricts
you from joining
a number of groups so there's no real
restriction so have a look click on the
link see what they say about the groups
and then
all you need to do is submit a request
to join and normally you hear about from
the administrator
in a couple of days depending on who the
administrator is and how busy they are
when you're in the group do not feel um
obliged that you have to comment you
have to
like things but it does actually help in
terms of forming relationships that if
you see someone
um that you want to connect with then
obviously
you reach out you connect with them you
send them a personalized request
introducing who you are
explaining that you've recently
transitioned into that particular field
or you're
aspiring um or looking to transition
into that field and that you're building
up
your network of professionals in that
area that makes you a lot more memorable
so i have to say to my students if i'm
receiving 10 or 12
connect requests each day and they're
blank the ones that are going to stand
out for me are the one or two
people who take the time and effort and
personalize it because it then makes me
feel that they've taken the time and
effort to really look at what i do
and really try to make that that
connection with them in terms of
do you share similar interests okay
that's one way of searching the other
way you can do the search so if you move
on to the next slide
some of you will have a list of
companies that you know you would like
to work for so you already know the
industry
that you want to work for and in this
example you'll see that
this is a screenshot from netflix's
netflix's linkedin page and the
difference with that is if for example
you were thinking well i really love to
work for netflix i'd like to connect
with some people at netflix
what you can do on this is you will see
on the left hand side you're going to
have all these tabs and one of them is
people
and if you're clicking people you can do
search that way so
you might decide to look say data
analyst at netflix or digital marketing
um junior digital marketing person at
netflix and if you're clicking the job
or if you just click on people
you should get a list of people who work
at that organization be able to see
their job titles
so that's another way of connecting with
people
via linkedin and using linkedin as a
connecting tool for networking
so let's just move on to the next slide
so virtual networking so this is
obviously
um our new world now so covert 19 has
significantly impacted the way we do
many things and one of which is events
and virtual networking meetings have
become a very common replacement for
face-to-face
networking events um i must have i've
also attended some mega networking
events that have gone on and some of you
may also have done so
so if you're attending one have a game
plan
so what do i mean by that well having a
game plan is sort of
don't just go there and sort of think
well i'll see what's going on
go there with a plan in mind so how many
people do you want to connect with right
what are you looking for in that network
so here i'll give an example maybe you
might say
what i want to get out of this
networking session is i will connect
with three new people
right when you're there act as if you
were attending a face-to-face event so i
know
you know virtually generally we only see
people sort of
top up and we don't really see the
bottom of each other obviously nature of
virtual networking
but um you never know when for some
reason
you may have to get up you may have to
get up and walk out the room for some
reason
you may have to get up and do something
and obviously you want to look
presentable
from head to toe because whether it's
face to face or virtual
first impressions still last and can
make an impact
turn up on time so even if you feel that
you're simply dialing in
and turning up on time speaks volumes
be prepared again when somebody asks you
what do you do this is
where it's really ideal to have your
pitch ready right
you want to be able to feel comfortable
and relax and just be able to
explain quite competently what it is
that you do
be authentic be yourself if you're not
yourself you know people will see
many different sides of you and you want
to show consistency
whether you're at a face-to-face event
whether you're at a virtual event
watch your body language so even though
you're online people will watch to see
are you slumping
are you fidgeting do you touch your face
a lot so that speaks volumes about
your confidence and how you feel and
remember you know
listen and also ask questions and if you
make
connections via these virtual meetings
always follow up afterwards so um you
may exchange emails online but remember
within at least 48 hours to 72 hours
you want to be able to send them for
example a linkedin connection or you
want to send a text and just say thank
you for
um it'd be great to connect with you or
have a conversation with you at a later
date or a time
really seal and start building on that
relationship as soon and as quickly
as possible so we're going to move on to
the next slide
which is our final poll for the session
okay and so this final poll is
i'm looking to understand have you asked
people within your network for any of
the following so have you ever asked
people in your network
for an information informational
interview have you asked them for career
advice or have you
asked them for a referral so i
am just going to launch that poll oh was
that still up there apologies everyone i
didn't realize
so i am going to launch this
last poll
have you asked people in your network
for any of the following
hopefully you can see that now good yeah
informational interview career advice
referrals so what have you asked people
in your network
for what have you felt comfortable and
confident
about asking people in your network for
okay so bearing in mind your needs what
are your needs in terms of
achieving your career goals
okay we have 58
in okay keep those votes coming in
please great to get a
a good sample of how you've been using
networking so
far what you've done and it's
interesting to understand what you feel
has worked for you
okay sixty-four percent is it to find
good
and give you guys
a couple
more seconds keep them coming in 66
it'd be great to get a bit higher
results quite interesting actually what
people have felt comfortable doing
what people have actually asked people
for and i will share that with you all
okay let me give you guys 10 65
yep let's get out a bit more if we can
at least get it to seventeen that's
great there's a number of you
who have little people in the poll yeah
hi jackie
there's one of the students who made a
good comment he said that there should
be a fourth
option which is none because it's
possible for some people that it could
be nice
maybe some of you have done none and
yeah that's a good point
some of you may well have done none and
if you haven't done any
um it be please you know feel free to
put that in the chat
because it'd be interesting to know how
many of you have done none
yep okay i can see some people actually
putting none down
okay
interesting a lot of you have done none
so you've got all this
this pool of resources
sitting in your content bank
your professional content bank
wow a lot of you've done none so yeah
that should have been a fourth option
i'd take that
on board next time so that's great
yep okay i'm gonna end this poll now so
that you guys can see
the results are in okay and
i'm gonna share so you can see so with
those of you who have voted
and who have actually reached out to
people in your network
52 have actually reached out for career
advice
23 have reached out for referrals and 15
for informational interviews and it's
quite interesting um
how many of you have actually reached
out for career advice but not gone
the next step of asking for an
informational interview or a referral
and we're actually going to look at
informational interviews
uh in upcoming in the next few slides
which hopefully will give you guys a bit
more confidence in how you go about
actually asking and requesting one okay
so i'm going to stop sharing this now
and we are going to move on to our next
slide
okay so moving on should be on slide 22
okay so this is going back to continuing
what i was just talking about
informational interviews so once you've
categorized
people within your network and you've
actually started reaching out and
building up a relationship with certain
individuals
you may then want to move on to a more
formal approach such as an informational
interview and a referral is another
another type of
type of more formal approach and so for
those of you who are wondering what is
an informational interview
well this is an informal meeting with
someone who works in a career
or has experience or knowledge in an
area of interest to you
you start it by making an initial
request so request so
you can make an initial request for an
informational interview
by email you can do it by phone through
linkedin or some other form of contact
in which
you will ask for 20 to 30 minutes of
another person's time
okay and then you know you will also
need to be clear
and concise about what you're looking
for out of that session
so you'll need to be clear about who you
are why you're contacting them
what your purpose is and this goes back
to my point about when i said when you
initially reach out to people
you want to personalize it you want to
personalize it
so already you're becoming memorable to
them
when they're posting things on linkedin
or they're sharing posts or they're
commenting on something
you also want to from time to time like
their post because
then you appear in their feeds from time
to time so you're not going to be a
distant memory the whole time
you will pop up from time to time in
their feed and that makes it easier for
you to go out
and to be able to make that connection
and say you know hey um
you're in my network and you've been you
know i've seen you
put some interesting posts out there and
then you can go on to kind of
move it on towards leading up to asking
for one of these informational
interviews
so moving on to the next slide it's
about preparing for the session
okay so now we're on the next slide so
like i'm saying before because you are
initiating this contact
you need to be prepared to leave the
session right you will be asking the
questions to gain
information about a particular industry
or company
so make sure you have your questions
prepared before
you contact the individual so you'll
probably need to spend some time
really thinking about what it is that
you want to get out of that session
do your research so make sure you have
done your research on the individuals
and acknowledge their accomplishments
be considerate remember that the
individual's time is valuable
let them know how much you appreciate
them considering your quest or taking
time out to help
you remember to state plenty you are not
asking them for a job
you are merely seeking information to
help progress your career
so let's move on to the next slide right
and um just to add to that what i would
say
is that sometimes you may go out you may
ask an informational request and they
may say no because they're too busy and
that's absolutely fine
if you get that response then just go
back to them and say well hey i
appreciate
knowledge and understand you may be busy
can i send you my questions in an email
can i email
you my questions to you and then you can
get back to me with
an answer in your own time okay the main
thing to do is try and keep
that connection and that that
conversation open
maybe they can't do it then maybe they
can agree to do it next month or maybe
they're happy for you to reach out to
them at a later date
but just kind of keep it open and just
don't feel that because they've said
no that's an instant closed door okay
so on this slide what i've done is
um i've listed a couple of examples or
questions you could ask at an
informational interview
and one of the things you're going to
want to do is to try to keep
your questions open-ended okay because
this will engage the person in
conversation rather than making it yes
or no question
and so some of the things that you might
be interested so this is just an example
of what i presented it may not be
exactly what you would want to ask
but think about what information you can
gain and remember
the advantage of these informational
interviews is that it allows you enables
you to gather and gain data
from that person or about an
organization that you cannot find
anywhere else you cannot find it out on
the internet if you do
some research about the company you
can't find it on their website
this is you know really insight data
which you can take away
and then you need to decide what you
want to do with it maybe not everything
that they say
um you will find value in but you have
that pool of information that you can
decide maybe this will help me
um for an upcoming interview which may
be at their organization or for other
upcoming interviews in that field
so let's just take a look at some of
these questions quickly because i know
time is going
um so you might want to ask about their
background and how they came to hold
their current position
you may want to question what general
skills are required in this line of work
what are some of the challenges of your
job or your organization
is facing you may want to ask them what
does their typical day look like
what do their day-to-day
responsibilities involve for example
you may want to ask them what kind of
decision-making do they do or they
participate in
things like what does you know what
skills do their company value or what's
valuable to their company at the moment
again i put you know what skills
attributes and abilities are essential
for success in the shop or field and you
may want to go a step further and be
futuristic thinking
how do they think that the job that
they're doing will change in the next
five years
and that kind of helps you to also gauge
maybe
what skills or additional skills you
might need going forward or as you go
through
your studies so let's move on to the
next line
and i'm just going to take away points
because i want you guys to have time for
q
a um and i'm appreciate that we're
coming up near to uh
two o'clock so take away points quickly
remember networking benefits what the
benefits are it can boost your career
enhance your visibility
and enable you to meet prospective
mentors okay so those of you who are
particularly those of you who are
looking for mentors
you know and you don't have anyone in
the media your immediate network or
anyone you immediately know
who can mentor you and help you kind of
climb further up the ladder
or move towards your your chosen career
you really need to sort of
start sussing out who might be um a
potential
mentor in your network
remember it's not about the quantity of
your connections but the quality
okay also don't ask for favors too
soon make sure you get to know the
person it's the same way as if somebody
goes out to you on day one and comes out
to you on day two and ask for an
informational interview
okay nobody likes to feel used
have a glam plan so what are you hoping
to achieve
out of the meeting um or you know
whatever engagement you're having with
the individual
also be prepared have your pitch ready
okay
and this also includes um you know at
your
informational interview being prepared
also with
other application materials so if they
ask you for your resume for example
at an informational interview you want
to be able to present
it straight after the virtual meeting
um you don't want to be waiting you know
for a week while you get it ready you
don't want to keep them waiting for a
week when you get it ready and send it
over to them
because that is how a lot of the times
people have had internal referrals they
have an informational interview and that
resulted that informational interview
that person may have asked them
for their resume or that person that
you are having that informational
interview you may feel that you strike
up such a good relationship with them
you may feel
that actually the doors open for you to
ask them if they would be
willing to um you know hand
your resume or your cv over to hr
or someone internally within the
organization
so really you know when i say prepare
for your informational interview be
prepared
holistically also be authentic
trust is gained when you show a pattern
of consistent behavior
all right and do ask for help okay you
can ask
for help in terms of you can have a
one-to-one to tailor specifically for
you
what networking strategy you think will
work best for you
um you know book a career coaching
session with us
you know there's a number of us as
coaches and you know for those of you
who have coaching sessions available
do you know feel free to use this to go
through your pitch pitch or practice
your pitch
okay and then also do remember
to follow up so send a thank you note
after an informational interview
let them know that you appreciate them
taking time out so if this was in a
pre-covered world
and you um maybe weren't too far away
from the person that you're you're
networking with so they're in your
locality i would suggest meeting
face-to-face and offering to pay for
their
drink or coffee as a way of showing your
appreciation
obviously in this environment we can't
do that because everything has to be
done at a distance
but in any event you really want to show
your appreciation and you still want to
be able to say to them
listen if there's anything you feel i
can do for you
um then you know please do give me a
shout because like i said before it
needs to be two-way
okay and follow up even after a
networking event right so this is about
within 48 to 72 hours make sure you send
that connect request
on linkedin or um that text or that
message however it is whether it's on
facebook
whatever slack whatever channel you're
going to be using connect with them as
soon as possible
and so ladies and gentlemen that brings
us to the end
of our webinar i know we started a few
minutes late so maybe we can do a quick
a couple of minutes for any q and a's
questions you may have so um
thank you very much so do you have any
questions let's have a look in the chat
so jackie
aj had placed a question and i said
jackie will answer this
his question is um
do you really need to have a couple of
projects done and your resume updated
before you start reaching out
you don't need to have them already done
when you first start reaching out but
what i would say is when you start to
move on to the stage
where you are requesting informational
interviews
and particularly where somebody said yes
and they're willing to speak to you
i highly recommend it because there's
nothing worse than sort of having this
you know engagement with someone really
feeling that you've hit it off well
and they may say to you actually um
you've just triggered my mind we've got
this opening in our organization
um we've only been it's not really been
published publicly because like i said
to you
only 20 of of roles really that i will
you be aware of that are publicly
advertised
and if they said to you the role closes
in two days you really want to be ready
to
send that resume across to that
individual
so that they can refer it onward as
quickly as possible
if you don't it's not the end of the
world but it just means that you might
find yourself
under pressure time pressure to be able
to cobble all your documents and your
information together and get it in
um the required format you know and get
it refined and just as you want it
before the deadline or the timeline
closes or before it loses the momentum
right because if you leave it at a week
you know the moment is not as hot as as
you do it straight after that session
let's see any other questions for us
so aj i have responded to you it
requires a specific discussion
one-on-one
for your question um jackie there's one
more question from josh he says i would
like to ask whether you have any tips
for asking a referral
being a fresher when you haven't built
an extensive network yet
okay so when you're a fresher it also
it also depends on your your unlike do
make use
of your alumni network right because
sometimes and i'm not sure if
it you know if you have that where you
are but sometimes your alumni network
also has connections with certain
industries and certain individuals and
if they do
see if you can get um whoever is kind of
in charge of the alumni network
to be able to make referrals that's
often the easiest way or at least
introduce you to people
that you can engage with who may be able
to make a referral for you
remember with referrals the thing is
people still need to know stuff about
you
okay because when somebody makes a
referral about you
um they need to have the confidence that
you can do what you say you do
and so there still needs to be that
element of trust uh so you still need to
make
that connection you still need to get to
know
that person but what you should do is
have a short bio even though you're
fresher
have a short bio still have your pitch
right
um you know what you want to do you know
what you where you want to go
and make use of your alumni network
right
um some universities will have a
linkedin one some will have a facebook
one someone have both
or slack one and really reach out to
also
other people um who are in a similar
position with you
so that also you can you can have sort
of that pair accountability where you
can both
work together and practice your pitch so
you feel confident in
reaching out to people that your
university or your institution
are affiliated with so you're going to
want to first reach out to people
they're affiliated with
because when you connect with people in
that organization you can mention your
university and of course
it will already spark oh yeah we know
that institution you're a fresher from
there okay great
so you've already got that initial
connection and it should make it a bit
easier for the conversations to start
flowing
and for you to be able to just talk
about yourself what you do
and where you want to go
so i hope that helps
so jackie there's one more question
which says
it unprofessional to ask if they can
connect us to the company's hr business
partner
or a department head that you want to
engage
in case of potential opportunities in
the future
so again it isn't necessarily
unprofessional
but it depends on how well so this goes
back to my point of
feeling people's energy and their vibe
and understanding how well you connect
with them
so if you've been warming up and you've
sort of had a series of
um conversations or engagements with
them over the
you know whether it's you've spoken to
them on the phone from time to time
maybe a quick call
or whether you've just been engaging
with them on linkedin or facebook
you may feel actually me and this person
have got a good enough relationship
where i feel i can reach out to them
um alternatively the way to phrase it is
you know
i would really like to look for
opportunities in your organization
could you tell me who the best person
would be for me to
you know forward or send my resume to
in your company that opens the door
for them to decide whether or not to say
to you
please oh just send it to me and i'll
afford it internally okay so you've left
it open so either they can come back to
you and say well yeah i can give you a
name
um and then you go off and do it or they
might offer to do it yourself so rather
than saying to them can you pass this on
leave it open and say this is what you'd
like to do you'd like to apply for their
organize to their organization
you're wondering if there are any
opportunities that might be suitable you
may be a suitable fit
and you're just wondering who the best
person is to apply to and when the best
time is
to reach out to them
okay
so jackie we do have questions that are
going on coming in
and i think the time is up in case you
have time we could pick up just one more
question and then the students could
come on the students hub
during the hotline chat session and they
could place their questions and the
coaches who are online will be more than
happy to answer
them would you like to pick up one more
question yes let's do that
we did start a few minutes late so let's
pick up one more question
so ludes is asking how to connect
without experience in the field
i am transiting mine is artificial
intelligence
okay so this is where it's really good
for you to
join some of the groups so this is my
point about going on to linkedin
and joining groups and people are often
you know when you join the network group
so there are a lot of artificial
intelligence groups on linkedin
that you could join and this is going to
be about you then looking
at people who have posted comments or
just going through and identifying
people that you think would be
really helpful to you to connecting so
when obviously you click on their names
you can look at their profile right
so one of the best ways for you to start
off is rather than going straight for
someone senior
you may want to connect with somebody
who's more junior okay
or somebody who when you click on their
profile you can see that they've made a
transition
why because they're probably more likely
to help you they will understand what
you're going through and the fact that
you're just gaining that experience and
trying to transition yourself
and they're more likely to kind of see
that connection and want to also help
out and reach out and help you
and this goes to the pac to the point of
making that
personalized message that personalized
connect request
and at that first connect request that
is where you're going to mention
listen i've just read you know i'm
working into transitioning
into this area i'm building up my
experience i'm building up my product
experience
i'm studying whatever it is and then you
you make the connection with them i've
noticed that you've recently started
working in this field
from this day just wondered if you could
share your experience of how you managed
to make that transition
so it's making that connection if you
look back for example
and you may find that okay you don't
have an experience but you may see
something in common so maybe
they're at udacity as well then you can
kind of pull that out and say hey i
noticed that you studied at udacity too
um i'm currently you know in this field
and i'm making the same transition
would it be possible for you to share
some tips so even if you don't want to
set up an informational interview with
them
you can always ask them to share some
tips maybe they can share some helpful
trends or some podcast or some blog that
they think that will help you to
or refer you even say or is there
someone you feel that you can refer me
to that can give me further guidance or
advice
um and just really um start it off that
way
don't try and make big leaps or big
steps little steps
to begin with
so you know and you know like mira was
just saying um i mean i'm gonna be
me and mira both have our um student hub
hour uh hotline hour tomorrow rather
than today
but you know like me was saying any of
the coaches can still pick up your
queries
if you want to pop into the student hub
tomorrow um
where me and mira at different times
will be online we can probably pick up
queries as well
and of course you know if you want to
avail yourself of the one-to-one
sessions that's even better because then
we can really give you more one-on-one
um tailored
advice on what you can do in steps you
can take and how you can use this
information
to your advantage
okay guys i hope you guys have found
that helpful we're gonna have to
obviously come to an end now um because
we've gone a bit over time but i really
appreciate all of you being here thank
you
for taking the time to come and
um really just be on this session and
for engaging in the polls
it's great thank you all so much
wherever you are in the world whether
it's nighttime morning day
enjoy the rest of your day alright and
take care and stay safe
bye all
you